after watching the fourth scream we were
left wondering the same thing Kirby dies
right this was left up in the air for a
while but according to this behind the
scenes picture of Hayden Panettiere
hanging out on set for Scream Six with
Jasmine Savoy Brown we officially have
our answer she gets stabbed but she
lived Hayden stepped away from acting
altogether back in 2018 after struggling
with her mental health I'm so happy that
this is gonna be like my first project
back she loves the character so much and
she feels it'll make for an easier
transition back into the Limelight for
her I'm excited I'm really excited